saying the president felt like he could
walk out of the hospital today
president trump tweeted quote with their
help i am feeling well
washington correspondent jesse tanner
joins us live now with more on this
tonight hi jesse
good evening we even heard from
president trump himself tonight in a
video that he tweeted making this the
first time that we've heard from him
since he became a patient there at
walter reed
saying that he went there because he
wasn't feeling so well now he's doing
much better
but he did acknowledge that these next
couple days will be critical in his
recovery
his doctors agree but they do say he's
improving
the president is doing very well after
his first night at walter reed medical
center
president trump's doctors painted a
positive picture of his condition
the president's been fever-free for over
24 hours navy commander dr
sean conley said he treated president
trump with the anti-viral medication
remdevier
and an experimental antibody drug as the
president
i didn't want to hold anything back if
there was any possibility that it would
add value to his care and
expedite his return i wanted to take it
conley said the president had a light
cough but never had difficulty breathing
and doesn't need extra oxygen all
indicators are that
he'll remain off of oxygen going forward
president trump walked out of the white
house friday evening wearing a mask
and giving a thumbs up to reporters in a
pre-taped interview he said
i think i'm doing very well but we're
going to make sure that things work out
conley said the president will work from
the hospital until the medical team
decides it's okay for him to return to
the white house
every day we're evaluating does he need
to be here conley said if necessary
president trump may need to stay at
walter reed to finish the full five-day
course of from desevere treatment
a growing list of trump administration
officials and republican lawmakers
have tested positive for covid19 since
the president's
diagnosis and dr conley did confirm
today that the white house is leading
contact tracing efforts
reporting in washington i'm jessie tanor
thank you so much jesse
october is breast cancer awareness month
and a number of community groups are
working to support survivors and
patients